all right go right ahead
oh all right perfect thank you all right
good morning everyone it's 9 00 a.m i'm
going to call the
house in a committee to order
i have a little script i have to read
as chair of the environment agricultural
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result result of the occurred 19
pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number
12.
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this publicly is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zune
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaneously
listen
and if necessary participate in this by
the zoom platform or by telephone
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and isa 91a
accessing the meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs
ledge.state.new us
every month the public is unable to
access the meeting
adjourned and rescheduled christina is
the staff assisting us today
there's no benefits that are taken
during this session shall be done by
roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking your
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
so sitting in as our clerk today is my
vice chair uh representative erin so if
you would please call the roll
thank you mr chair
first on our roll call chairman howard
i am here in the committee room
vice chairman judy aaron i am here
representative contra
representative
[Music]
davis i'm here in the committee
representative stapleton
representative i am here
i'm in my home i'm alone in my room but
my husband is working
from home thank you
representative kennedy representative
kennedy
representative mason i
am here in my office in my home in
claremont new hampshire
and i'm alone that's representative
stapleton good morning
representative sanborn i am here in my
home
all by myself senator bixby
um i am uh present in my home in dover
and i am by myself
and just as a separate note uh for the
uh for christine
uh representative pearl's uh audio seems
to be really crackly so if you could
look into that at some point thanks
thank you
representatives
representative jetsey
representative murray
representative murray here i am in my
yard
just a point of order if i may mr chair
yes a couple of members are not able to
find the zoom link
okay i will go ahead and send them out
um mr chair and
i will have um i the it department come
look at your mic
because you are going in and out i think
it might be the chips
so if kaplan representative kathleen
senator pilot
yes rep hyland is here my video's off to
kind of help with my broadband issues
but i'm here alone in my office thank
you
thank you good morning representative
representative perez
okay that's it
uh chairman carl will be with us
momentarily
sorry i was trying to find another mic
here i could use um
okay sorry about the technical
difficulties is that any better on the
volume of the voice quality
anybody out there it's about the same
i'm going to contact it but and then
i'll be sending out the extra zoom links
when people come in i'll let you know
okay thank you very much
all right we're going to open up a
presentation
and my apologies for the technical
difficulties here to those folks that
are presenting but we will uh
make the best of it hopefully before you
have to say it too much you can hear me
again so i'm going to turn it over to uh
doctor
and i'll apologize if i get your name dr
shaco is that correct
yeah psycho ronschaiken scheikel okay
thank you very much
dr scheiker i appreciate you and the
students coming today
it's our pleasure so on behalf of the
class of 1964 policy research shop at
the nelson a rockefeller center at
dartmouth
we have two presentations to make today
one on pesticides and neonicotinoids
together on solid waste management
and i've talked with chairman pearl and
i think we'll start with the
neonicotinoids
group that would be purity emily and
jeremy
and uh we'll turn the four over to them
and we'll
we're hoping for a 15-minute
presentation with 15 minutes of
discussion and then we'll go to the
second project
after that so i'll turn it over to the
to uh emily parity and to jeremy
thank you look forward to it go ahead
and
go ahead and do the presentation and
then we'll hopefully be able to ask you
some questions
sorry one moment
can everyone see my screen
okay so good morning everyone thank you
to chairman pearl
and the environment on agriculture
environment and agriculture
um for hearing our testimony today my
name is parity capadea and i
along with my group members emily liu
and jeremy rodriguez
have compiled a presentation to showcase
our research
on the topic of pesticides and
neonicotinoids on behalf of the policy
research shop at rockefeller center
so with that i'll pass the baton to
jeremy who will begin with a brief
overview of pesticides
hi everyone uh so just to clarify this
particular section will only cover
pesticides
um and to introduce them we conducted a
literature view of the
effect of pesticides on human health so
in a review we found a considerable body
of research explaining the detrimental
effects of pesticides to the human body
um pesticides can cause immediate health
effects on on contacts such as rashes
blisters blindness nausea
and even death in some cases they can
also cause long-term health effects
some of the literature we reviewed found
connections between alzheimer's disease
and organophosphates and growing
chlorines
asthma and herbicides birth defects like
spinal bifida
and nitrates brain cancers and
insecticides and herbicides
and a number of other diseases linked to
pesticide exposure in our analysis we
also noted the higher rates of health
issues among farmers and agricultural
workers
an estimated 44 of farmers are poisoned
uh by pesticides every year
according to recent studies um and some
of this burden is due to close proximity
to pesticide application and phenomenons
like pesticide drift
which is essentially chemicals that do
not reach the target crop
um that is then carried away by wind and
with some application technologies only
10 of the pesticide actually reaches the
target crop
and that pesticide drift can reach as
far as 50 miles from the original site
this occupational risk of farmers also
affects their families
one study found increased concentrations
of pesticide metabolite in the urine of
children and farmers
exposure can occur either by direct
pesticide drift or from farmers carrying
pesticides on their clothing and
protective equipment is mandated by the
worker protection standard but we found
many studies studying that farmers still
experience significant exposure
even when wearing wps recommended
building practices
lastly migrant and seasonal farmers are
arguably
um the high uh at the highest
vulnerability because of their social
economic and linguistic
marginalization that our exams have been
exacerbated by
occupational hazards poverty and poor
living conditions
they're also more likely to be paid less
and experience more occupational
injuries and illness related to
pesticide exposure
now pass it on to emily who will delve
into neonicotinoids
thanks jeremy to shift gears a little
bit now we're going to be focusing
specifically on
neonicotinoids or neonics for short
which are a widely used neurotoxic
insecticide
and so like nicotine it binds to nerve
cells and
insects this over stimulates them and
ultimately kills them
in terms of usage neonics are applied in
over 120 different countries
and have 140 different crop uses
including rice and cotton
and some non-agricultural applications
include golf courses lawns and gardens
and here's a map of omidicloprid usage
in the u.s which is one type of neonic
and as you can see it is
widely used throughout the country and
unix are particularly effective against
sap beating insects such as aphids and
in new hampshire neonics are frequently
used in apple orchards
so neonics are water soluble which means
that they dissolve when in contact with
water
so they can be applied to the soil or
sprayed but they're primarily used
as a seed treatment which means that all
parts of the plant will take up the
neonic as the plant grows
and the munich is present in the pollen
and nectar
and treating seeds reduces the need for
multiple multiple pesticide sprays
which makes coated seeds a widely used
option
for example in 2015 between 79 and 100
of corn seed was actually already
pre-coated with neonics
and here's a table that sums up some
agricultural manufacturers that include
neonic compounds in their products and
as you can see
a lot of these are household names
let's talk briefly about pesticide
regulation in the states
the division of pesticide control within
the new hampshire department of
agriculture markets and foods oversees
pesticide licensing in the state
and so licensing involves exams and
applications and the division issues
licenses to both
commercial and private applicators as
well as pesticide dealers
while the core materials of required
exams focus
on pesticide safety and environmental
concerns broadly
neonics have become a topic covered
during recertification education
and so for an individual to maintain a
pesticide license in the state
every five years they must attend
educational seminars
and stay up stay updated on pesticide
knowledge and that currently includes
neonics
in addition in recent years exams for
required for supervisors of commercial
applicators
have also consistently covered bee
health and neonic use
finally the division is able to enforce
these regulations and licensing
protocols
through random field checks and
implement various punishments for
violations
while neonics are widely used within the
last decade
new studies have raised some concerns
that there may be some downfalls
as unix may have a negative impact on
non-target organisms
specifically bees also known as
pollinators
there's currently some conflicting
research as to the exact effects of
neonics on the health of these
and this is because experiments have
been a little inconsistent in their
methodology and then their outcomes as
well
so however the majority of laboratory
and semiconductors
demonstrate that neonics are associated
with increased mortality
impaired feeding and reduced colony
growth in bees
and in one lab setting showed that a
connection between
low doses of imidacloprid which is one
type of munich
and colony collapse disorder or ccd
which is a phenomenon in which
bees abandon their hives during the
winter and die
however it should be noted that cct has
actually been declining since 2008
and can be caused by a number of
different factors including
parasites habitat loss and environmental
changes
so pinning ccd exposure alone would not
capture that full picture
that being said a recent report
published by honeybee researchers at
cornell does
highlight the risks of munich exposure
to honeybees
so using some hazard data including
toxicity and then exposure data as
metrics for risk
a wide scale meta-analysis revealed that
neonic treated seeds
specifically cause high risk to bees and
according to that report
in and near corn and soybean fields
receiving
pre pre-treated and unique seeds
74 of exposures are likely to impact
honeybee behavior a 58 percent
are sorry physiology 58 of exposures
impact honeybee behavior
and 37 percent of exposures will impact
honeybee reproduction
in addition unix may also impact humans
in some harmful ways
and human exposure to neonics can come
through contaminated food
or drinking water or even occupational
uses and within one systematic review
chronic exposure studies reported some
adverse health effects such as
congenital heart disease and memory loss
however exposure
must be really significant for neonics
to cause acute toxological effects
and this is because neonics have been
selected to be specific
for uh acetylcholine receptors in
insects
and they therefore show low affinity for
bitter vertebrate and human receptors
and are less toxic
humans than older insecticides are and
unix also typically do not pass
the blood brain barrier which prevents
toxins from getting to the space where
neurons are
in human brains and this also reduces
the potential for
mammalian toxicity and that concludes
the section on neonic risk i'll go ahead
and pass it off to
my colleague purity to discuss some of
the potential benefits for neonics
thank you emily so in addition to
evaluating the potential risk to
pollinators we also evaluated potential
benefits of neonicotinoids
and namely we relied on the same study
that emily mentioned
by honeybee researchers in cornell who
examined the potential risk and benefit
of neonic use or non-use in new york
and so they conducted economic analysis
on crops in new york
and they conducted or they examined over
5 000 paired trials
on different crops in new york to
examine the effects
on on crops and so they conducted
research on a number of different farms
and found that
majority of the trials conducted on
fruits and vegetables
showed that neonic use does in fact
reduce pest populations
limit crop damage or improve yield
compared to
untreated control plots and so there is
a significant
benefit to farmers for using
neonicotinoids
there's direct economic benefit that was
found by this group of researchers
the one caveat that the researchers did
find
is that the potential benefits of
neonicotinoids are
more limited for certain crops compared
to others
so in 83 to 97 of the field trials they
examined
there was no significant increase or
decrease in corn yields
when neonicotinoid treated seeds were
used compared to pyrethroid chemical
alternatives or other untreated control
seeds
so this translates to more infrequent
economic benefits for corn farmers who
use neonics
um yet as my colleague emily mentioned a
significant portion of conventional
field core farmers do use
neonic treated seeds the study also
found similar results for soybean crops
and they found that 82 to 89 of field
trials found no increase or decrease
in soybean yields compared to the
chemical alternatives
and the epa also released a study 2014
now revealed that seed treatments
provided negligible overall benefits
to soybean production some more research
is
needed on this topic especially in
relation to crops that are specific to
new hampshire
the the study also could not account for
differences between pest pressure and
yield response associated with certain
crops
which did vary between the farms and the
data did not also
account for the insurance value of using
neonics in a preventative manner
so more research is needed on this data
to assess the potential economic
benefits to farmers in new york
um specifically for assorted vegetables
apples hay and sweet corn which are
major crops in new hampshire so now pass
it on to
jeremy who briefly give an overview of
different states regulations
on neonics over the past few years
um so oh um
okay sorry um so in our report we also
connected
um across state analysis with states
that have existing neonic regulation
vermont passed hb 205 in 2018 which made
neonics a restricted use pesticide
meaning that only state certified
applicators can use neonics
the bill was influenced by the
significant increase if you have colony
loss in 2017
and the bills essentially banned
consumer use and uh increased
the annual registration fee for
pesticides to offset inspection costs of
pesticides and develop educational
services
it also requires uh beekeepers to
register with the agency
of agriculture food and markets and
submit a pest mitigation plan
in 2014 minnesota passed hf2798 which
focused on informing consumers about
plants
treated with neonics through labels
however a large portion of neonic use in
minnesota it goes unregulated through
uh treated seeds which evade federal
regulation under the fifa
and like vermont uh maryland passed
legislation restricting the use of
neonics in 2018
to only certified applicators and
finally new york has the most recent
proposed legislation
which was introduced in 2021 the birds
and bees protection act proposes
elimination of neonics where risks two
partners outweigh
economic benefits the bill also proposes
bans on neonic
treated seeds for corn soybean and wheat
crops and other nuanced
bands
lastly we also conducted somewhat of a
case study examining the potential
effects of neonic regulation on planet
or health in connecticut
was the first state to restrict the use
of neonics in 2016
uh banning used by consumers through sb
neonics under the bill are not allowed
to be applied to plants that have
bloomed unless they're in a greenhouse
that's inaccessible to pollinators uh
the bill also sets up an infrastructure
to protect
pollinator health like the uh pollinator
advisory committee
um they also mandate um they also
mandated the model
uh model pollinator habitat education
and interventions
um in deforested areas um help
facilitate that those habitats um
connecticut experienced a large
percentage of b
uh colony loss at the beginning of 2015
through 2018
but that trend significantly decreased
at the end of 2018.
we were wondering how sp 231 impacted uh
colonies specifically in terms of
pesticide related deaths so we use the
national agricultural
statistics service to compile averages
on the table on this slide
given that sv-231 passed in 2016
one might expect a steady decline in
pesticide related losses of colonies
however
as you can see that trend decreased and
then increased again
and this essentially elucidates the need
for controlled experiments and the
underscores the complexity of the
situation as the economies can be
influenced by a variety of factors from
climate change to predators
disease weather and so on um
and to conclude um excited please
to conclude our research has shown that
the answer to neonic
regulation isn't simple and linear there
are numerous stakeholders who may be
impacted by regulation
or non-regulation and the complexity of
this neonic usage and its effects
uh make it even more difficult there's a
need for nuanced legislation
that is science-based and addresses the
concerns of the stakeholders involved
there are certainly economic benefits
from the use of neonics however
sometimes the benefits are negligible
for crops such as
corn and soybeans in the case of new
york
and all in all whatever the community
decides on it's clear that the
regulation needs to be nuanced
and content specific thank you
i think we're now open to questions or
comments from the committee
all right well thank you so a lot of
information in there to uh
try and digest quickly i'm glad you
sent the slides to the whole committee
so i guess we'll open it up to the uh
to the committee and see if anyone has
any questions
too many questions for jeremy emily or
caridi
representative aaron go ahead okay can
you hear me
everybody can hear me yes okay good
thank you
and thank you so much for this um
wonderful presentation it was very
informative and
um interesting i do have a couple of
questions and one
my first question is i i would direct to
emily
uh so in describing the study
uh and the effects of neonics
i was wondering if the study was based
on approved and proper use of
pesticide versus
the non-professional or uncontrolled use
that's more you know backyard farmer
or smaller farmer or you know
flower gardens that kind of thing
thank you so much for that question and
from my understanding
of this report they were all controlled
field studies so they were done in the
state of
new york under new york regulations and
so it was
less of the like backyard kind of
non-agricultural applications and more
of controlled field crop studies on
soybeans and corn if that answers your
question
okay thank you and i have
another follower yes i have a question
for jeremy as well
uh when you were discussing um
[Music]
you know the pesticides usage
i was wondering you know in other states
that
have restricted the use of these
pesticides
were they then using alternative
pesticides that perhaps
were worse because uh
you know there are several tools in our
toolbox for how to control
pests that attack different crops
i'm wondering you know if we if we
ban or restrict usage would that
then make people rely on
pesticides that are worse to the
environment
worse for our bees and worse for
uh the you know crops involved
um so we didn't collect data on
alternative uses for um in the states
that at least have uh
switched to um i've switched to new
restrictions
a lot of the states a lot of those
things i mentioned still utilizing unix
they're just
more restricted to only certified
applicators
um so i'm not sure about um
the use of other alternatives but i know
that those states still use neonics just
in many cases they're just restricted
and that answers your question
okay thank you thank you very much uh
representative mola has a question hi
chair
uh thank you so much for letting me
speak chair and thank you uh
for this great presentation i actually
learned a lot um
i one of the things that i like how it
focused on was the honeybee population
because i
uh i think that that's a real big issue
and it doesn't get a lot of attention
sometimes
or at least get a lot of wide discussion
i'll say that from people who aren't in
the scientific community
one of the things that i was kind of
curious about i would really like to see
first a comment then a question is i
would really like to see
if you all dig a little deeper into
vermont maryland and those states that
have restricted it
and maybe get a little deeper about how
they restricted it
and what what alternatives people have
been using since then
and uh what are maybe some outcomes
because that's always the
that's always the benefit of trying to
enter into any kind of new policy
is to understand what it looks like on
the back end if there's some information
for there so if you guys have any
information to that that you
that you know you'd work on next that
would be very interesting to hear
one of the questions that i have is that
um i understand that you were saying
more study needs to be done in
connecticut to understand why their
pest numbers sort of decreased and
increased and buried do you all have any
sort of
anecdotal thoughts on that or
or things that you might have come
across that say aren't necessarily
what you would put in a study but
something you would discuss because i'm
just curious about that
that fluctuation thank you
thank you for your question um so um
i i guess from a like a i guess personal
experience doing the research and
maybe emily and pretty can also add to
this um
it seems like that like the that
uh neonics are pretty um like the
effects are just not very well
understood especially in regards to
um like different types of plants like
in some cases they're a lot more
economically beneficial than others um
and some they're not at all and they
end up being more harmful um but
it the numbers seem to fluctuate because
also there's a lot of other
um factors that um are
kind of confining variables uh so
there's like weather disease
human interference uh climate change
uh predators like parasites were a huge
um
uh parasites were a huge threat to
bee colonies so i think it really it's
hard to like get concrete data and even
the the data that is collected
um often like has confounding variables
um so i feel
that like there needs to be really
controlled experiments to actually fully
understand
uh the effect of neonics on pollinator
health
moving forward i think sorry i don't
know if that answered your question
it it did chair may i have a follow-up
sure one more go ahead
uh i just quickly you know i think that
you're right i think there's a lot of
variables
variables to that and it would be really
interesting to sort of approach this
discussion
uh in the future also i'd be interested
knowing
for instance what plants are really
affected
by this and what what aren't
economically what which plants show
benefit what plants don't because that
actually might be
very useful in tailoring any kind of
restrictions
um for certain types of plants or
certain types of plant use
i again i'm just i'm not speaking from a
from perspective that you know that i i
know much about restricting uh this at
this point but
i just wanted to say that any specific
information that you guys can provide in
the future i think would be very very
interesting and very very
helpful uh going forward when you're
making any kind of policy decisions as
we try to grapple with that
thank you yeah definitely and that's
actually um
what new york did with the birds and
beats pollinator act and
birds and music protection act and they
used cornell to
follow up on that study and see which
crops were effective and which weren't
and i think a similar study would would
be really useful for new hampshire
just to learn about the specific context
of new hampshire and which
plants um are the most beneficial with
neonics
so thank you for your question thank you
thank you uh we'll take one more from
representative bixby and then in the
interest of time we'll have to move on
to the next section
representative dixie okay so
one thing that um you didn't i don't i
don't think you mentioned in the
presentation but was in
uh your uh uh was in the written report
was
that uh it there were there's something
there was something about
um about uh
neonicotinoids ending up in the
uh being measurable in the fruits and
vegetables
that uh the they had been used on
so um you know if you were for instance
if it was a squash then
um there would be uh traces of the
neonics
in the squash um
after the pesticide had been used and i
was wondering if
you could give a little bit more
information on that and also
some information on whether there are
restrictions about whether
you can use neonics um you know
within a certain time of flowering
sure i can speak a little bit to that
thank you for that question um
so it is a little the current mechanism
mechanism behind a translocation of
pesticides in plants
is pretty unknown or poorly known but
the i think what you were mentioning in
the report was that we cited that one
study in 2005 found that
some plants or some vegetables
specifically such as
leafy vegetables and tomatoes and
cucumbers have higher amounts of neonic
residues than others
and unfortunately with this study there
was no indication of what the
application method of the munich was
so that is something that certainly
needs additional research
but in terms of how neonics are
taken up by plants um we do know that
neonic compounds
are often kind of dispersed throughout
the environment instead of being
actually
taken up by the plant uh one study found
that
only about five percent of the active
ingredients of neonics are actually
taken up by the plants and
a lot of a lot of that other residue
and also chemical compound kind of um
is within the soil and then can also
lead to pesticide drift
so those are certainly concerns but
again the impacts of that on humans
is a little unknown because while
humans well while eunuchs do have lower
mammalian toxicity
and kind of the extent of exposure and
the resulting harm from that there's not
a ton of
literature currently
thank you i also sorry i wanted to
briefly mention i think this got skipped
over in the presentation
um but when we were speaking to
pollinator health experts they expressed
an interest in clarifying
some of the language around what emily
was talking about so i think some of the
language around
b toxic pesticides and whether they're
systemic
is kind of at dispute between different
fields and so systemic could refer to
something that is long lasting in the
environment or something that is taken
up fully by the plant
and i think the confusion of that term
perhaps in previous legislation about
the bill or just general legislation
throughout the country
um has kind of confused the policy
regarding that so i think maybe
clarification
as well as additional research would
help in that regard
thank you very much all right uh
dr shaco i guess we'll move on to the
next section
yep we've got uh kelly and frandi i'll
talk a bit about
sustainable waste management in new
hampshire so i'll turn it over to
frankie and kelly
all right
can everybody see that the presentation
yes we can
hi i'm frandi and i'm here with my
teammate khalid and we just want to
thank you guys for giving us a chance to
present our investigation on solid waste
management in new hampshire
um it means a lot to us that you took
the time out of your day to
listen to us um so
sorry to start off sideways management
in new hampshire has fallen far behind
out of neighboring states and the nation
as a whole within the past decades
and this primarily can be attributed to
the budget cods budget cuts that the
department of environmental services
solid waste management bureau has
experienced
over a decade ago the this bureau had a
planning and community assistance
section
whose duty was to oversee each
municipality to ensure that they were
receiving adequate assistance on solid
waste management
yet today the section finds itself with
only one active position
the lack of resources for each
municipality has also left them without
a standardized procedure with regards to
managing
managing municipal solid waste and has
contributed to the state's landfill
capacity rapidly dwindling
this is all exacerbated by the fact that
the last solid waste management plan of
the state was published in 2003
leaving municipalities to decide what
the best practices are
for themselves which proves to be a
difficult endeavor
it's also worth noting here that rsa
149m
states that the bureau has to update
their solid waste management plan every
six years
however that is not reflected in the
current reality of new hampshire
and here we can see that there are
currently only six
operating landfills in new hampshire
with three being public
and three of them being private and it's
worth
noting here that fifty percent of the
solid waste um disposed in these private
landfills
comes comes from out of state
particularly massachusetts which
has now an extensive plan to reduce the
amount of solid waste
in their own um state by 50 by 90
by the year 2050 which just worsens the
current problem here in massachusetts
i mean sorry and here in new hampshire
um four of these landfills are expected
to close
to have their earliest anticipated
closure date within the next decade
as depicted by the graph um evidently
new hampshire needs to do something now
if it wants to address the rapid
decrease in the state's plan for
capacity that could shape the future
for these reasons we ultimately decided
that we wanted to investigate what
techniques new hampshire could
potentially utilize
as alternatives to landfills and to
reduce the volume of solid waste
produced overall
also for each of the alternatives we
found we kept in consideration how
economically
and environmentally sustainable they
were for the state
now i'm going to talk a little bit more
about landfill gas energy
this is the first alternative disposal
method um to landfills that we
investigated
uh and though this alternative does not
directly reduce the volume of solid
waste in landfills
landfill gas energy facilities can make
existing landfills more environmentally
sustainable
by repurposing the landfill gas released
by solder waste
for context landfill gas is composed of
approximately 50
methane and 50 percent carbon dioxide
which are detrimental
to the environment what landfill gas
energy facilities do is that they
capture this gas through a series of
wells
and focus on drawing out the methane
since it could be repurposed into energy
this gas is then compressed and chilled
to draw any liquids through condensation
and is converted into energy through
either
electricity generation direct use of the
medium
or turn it into renewable natural gas
the resulting energy can then be sold by
to nearby clients or be used in the
facility itself
to lower its own emissions and reliance
on other fuels as well as costs
uh one main benefit of these facilities
is that they reduce greenhouse
greenhouse gas emissions uh municipal
solid waste landfills are the third
largest human generated source of
methane emission in the u.s
and so reducing these emissions from
landfill helps mitigate global climate
change
another benefit is that they repurpose
landfill gas in sustainable ways that
can bring about health
and safety benefits to local communities
they also reduce the odors or that are
emitted by landfills and
lessen any explosion hazards that can
result from the gas accumulation
in these landfills and lastly the
generated energy from these facilities
can also be sold
to nearby clients creating new revenue
streams for these municipalities
uh building these units also creates a
bunch of new jobs
related to the facility design
construction and operation
for our investigation specifically we
honed in on a landfill gas energy
facility
already operating in the state at
turnkey recycling and environmental
enterprise facility
and another operating essential landfill
in johnson rhode island
and to the right we can see a little bit
more information on central landfill
like how it generates
33.4 megawatts annually
reduces carbon emissions by 1.27 million
and saves 2.1 trillion btu per year
we discovered that while many landfills
in new hampshire have the appropriate
equipment to have
landfill gas energy facilities many of
them do not participate in the endeavor
that has been
particularly beneficial to the at the
aforementioned facilities
uh both of these facilities tend to show
how effective life for gaza energy is
with representatives from these
facilities saying that the project paid
itself back within a decade
it's also worth noting here that another
revenue stream in new hampshire
for the energy generated in these
facilities is through renewable energy
credits
that the state offers there are
currently two landfill gas energy
candidates in new hampshire one is in
lebanon and the other one is in
bethlehem
some considerations that the state must
deliberate on before implementing
alternatives is
one which technology will best fit for a
facility which will depend on the
landfill gas that's generated there
two it must compare the costs and
benefits and determine what what is the
most cost effective method
and whether they can pre it will
eventually pay itself out as it usually
does
and three it must determine the overall
economic and environmental impact on new
hampshire
now i'm going to turn it over to my
teammate kelly who's going to talk a
little bit more about wasted energy in
new hampshire
yeah um so another way of dealing
with um all the solid waste produced
in new hampshire is through
waste to energy technology mass burn
incineration is the most commonly used
waste energy technology
um with 75 operating plants in the us
currently um in these plants trash is
sort of
sorted to move any hazardous materials
or recyclables
on and then there is a large scale
combustion the heat generated from this
is used to convert water into steam
turning a turbine
on generator which produces energy
the ash generated from this is then
filtered for any other material that can
be burned again
and set and what's left over is sent to
the landfill which is much smaller
in mass than the original solid waste so
that would help
reduce the volume of solid waste going
into the landfills
these plants actually remove greenhouse
gas emissions by one ton of carbon
dioxide equivalents
for every ton of waste diverted from the
landfill instead of the methane
being released um
into the atmosphere from landfills
this is being converted to carbon
dioxide as it's burned um and some of
the new carbon capture
technologies make this a actually fairly
clean way to deal with solid waste on
they also have high economic benefits
with studies projecting that
a dollar 77 is injected into the economy
for every dollar of revenue generated
by the waste to energy um
sector we looked at the wheeler greater
concord
facility for waste to energy which is
the picture on the right as well as a
solid waste management
renewable energy facility in palm beach
county florida
um the clinton concord process is 191
600 or 191 600 tons of waste per year
on and the energy from that powers over
14 000 homes and saves about 195
000 barrels of oil every year um
so despite the fact that there is one
waste energy plant in new hampshire
building another one isn't the most
viable option for how to
reduce solid waste in new hampshire just
because
the nature of the size of or
of the amount of solid waste you need to
make this
worth it um new hampshire is a pretty
spread out state that works in concord
which is one of the more densely
populated areas
um so that's a limitation and
right now on new hampshire's hierarchy
of solid waste management
incineration is low um so they would
also
need to move that up and make it a more
favorable
way of managing waste in new hampshire
for this to be viable
and then the other way if we're not
creating new facilities we can
reduce the waste that is being
created right now 35 percent of
new hampshire's waste is recycled or
composted when it could be
up to 80 percent um so one solution is
passing more comprehensive
recycling legislation we looked at
examples in other states vermont
is one of them that has a pretty
comprehensive universal recycling law
which bans blue bin recyclables leaves
and yard debris and food waste
all from going into the trash in vermont
it establishes a pay as you throw policy
um
some of the parts like the food scrap
ban were phased in to give time for the
infrastructure to build up
and it did come at a significant cost it
cost the state of vermont about five
million dollars
a year to have this policy um
but even if new hampshire is not ready
to implement
a full comprehensive law like this there
are many parts
of the universal recycling law that
could be
adopted into new hampshire to reduce um
waste another piece of this of recycling
is glass recycling and bottle builds
right now most recycling in new
hampshire is single stream which means
the glass is too contaminated to be sold
back to the last companies
so with a passing a bottle bill which
they have in connecticut
maine massachusetts in vermont the glass
collected could be cleaner and able to
be sold back
and another thing new hampshire is doing
um
with glasses working with the nra
it has a program where they crush
recycled glass
down um and incorporate it into roads
um and so expanding that program could
help
divert some waste from landfills and
then finally
um a lot of waste in new hampshire comes
from out of state
in 2018 49 of the solid waste that was
filling up
new hampshire's landfills came from out
of state
um so by reducing or disincentivizing
states from
bringing their waste to new hampshire we
could
reduce the amount of waste going into
landfills um
one state we looked at as an example was
ohio they have
a surcharge for waste
that comes in from out of state that's
higher than the in-state cost
to the disincentivized out-of-state done
so the landfills in new hampshire are
filling up four of them have plans to
close in the next decade but
the rate of solid waste being produced
is not slowing down
so something needs to be done about this
issue
um and we came up with some
recommendations first is to update the
solid waste
management plan as friendly touched upon
this hasn't been
revised since 2003 a lot has changed
since 2003 so this needs
some updating um more funding could be
provided to the solid waste management
bureau of the apartment of develop
and department of environmental services
past budget cuts have left it virtually
unable to do its job managing
the waste and the state properly
um new hampshire could construct
additional landfill gas to energy
facilities in the landfill like friendly
said there are two
landfills that are ready to uh
or it's like very feasible to implement
this technology
could simulate the economy with job
creations
and help ameliorate the effects of
climate change and lower fuel costs
new hampshire can investigate and update
their solid waste hierarchy
waste energy is low but the technology
around waste to energy has changed a lot
recently it's gotten a lot cleaner
so that could be updated um
new hampshire could revisit update and
pass new legislation regarding recycling
and waste management and encourage
more recycling and more diverting waste
from landfills
um in regard to the glass recycling
roads regulated by the department of
transportation so that's more state
roads
are except either require the glass to
be crushed up so finely
um that it's hard for the nra to meet
those standards
right now they can only meet the
standards of roads regulated by the
department of environmental services so
if the department of transportation
regulations were studied and potentially
updated to be something that the nra
could feasibly
meet we could potentially incorporate
more recycled glass into
roads uh a surcharge could be
imposed on out-of-state waste to
participate in new hampshire landfills
and that revenue could be put back into
waste management in new hampshire
and finally new hampshire could continue
to partner with
organizations like the nri who are
coming up with creative
solutions to deal with waste management
to develop sustainable strategies
um and that's all we have and we'll take
questions now
great thank you both very much kelly i
assume that
uh you guys probably looked at the
legislation that we've been working on
currently uh house bill 413 and senate
bill 146
but have you guys taken a look at those
and because we were those are sort of in
the area of updating our
recycling uh goals did you get a chance
to review those
yeah i have seen those good
so we're we're starting to follow some
of your recommendations all right
yeah uh and i have one question
for you as well
so you talked about the um the
the landfill gas turning it into
electricity program
so why don't more of the new hampshire
landfills participate in that program if
they're able to
from my understanding it's they have a
little bit of a complication deciding
what specific technology works best for
them
and also a lot of the times they assume
that the best technology is the one that
fits
bigger facilities which is like
reciprocating engines
in reality however it has come up today
that micro turbines are actually super
helpful for
smaller facilities because you can scale
up the size
and also not waste as much money as you
would if you were to build
a facility that was far larger than the
landfill gas that was generated at the
facility itself
okay so it's more of a capital
investment issue than a revenue issue
yes okay thank you all right i'll open
it up
uh representative murray you have a
question yeah i do
um thank you for the presentation and
having served on
a previous study committee in the
legislature i think much of what you
were saying definitely resonates so i
appreciate
the time that you have taken one
question i did have
um with regard to the solid waste
hierarchy that you mentioned and
updating that
my understanding is that um that
the the state well they
the state department of des and the us
epa work very closely together and
outlining that hierarchy so
i'm just curious how
how how flexible you feel
because a lot of these things are highly
regulated at the federal level so i'm
just curious what kind of flexibility
you might see
um a state department amending that
hierarchy
yeah from our conversation with um the
palm beach county waste
energy facility we understood that
because there has been so many
different changes in the technology that
they use um with regards to waste energy
facilities
things have been more environmentally
friendly and the epa has
been more open to having it higher on
the hierarchy
for example i think they have an they
had a condensation process
at the end of the filtering process now
just to kind of take the water that is
generated from any
sorry any excess steam that is generated
from the turbines
and turn it into waters to reduce any
greenhouse gas emissions
um kelly do you have anything
we didn't look at exactly in our project
i don't think i came across
exactly how much of that is
federally regulated so i don't think we
fully have the answer to that
no no problem i appreciate it thank you
and then follow up mr chair if i may
sure go ahead um one other question that
i did have
to your interest in glass and so
some of the things i think you were
talking about with regard to glass
cullet but then it sounded like you were
also talking about potential programs
around glass bottling and is that
something you took
a look at as far as feasibility of
programs within the state of new
hampshire
versus our neighboring states or i'm
curious to know if there's more
information there
yeah um so a lot of as i mentioned four
other
new england states have these programs
um and it's essentially the sort of just
like bottle
return programs specifically
for glass um it seems like a pretty
feasible thing on to do
it showed in the other states having
high economic returns
on and there is a market right now
for recycled glass it just needs to be
clean um and not contaminated with other
materials and this seems like a way you
get
back much cleaner recycled glass
okay thank you very much all right
uh representative erin did you have a
question yes i did thank you
uh and i'd like to direct this to kelly
specifically
you were talking a lot about recycling
and as we've seen with china exiting the
recycling of plastics market
you know recycling only works if you
have an entity or a market
place uh who will take the waste to
process it
so what it what do you suggest
to encourage businesses to enter this
space
that's been created and and also
coupling that with what if there's
unsuitable technology to handle those
recyclable items
like certain plastics i mean we've got a
problem
where we want to encourage recycling to
happen
but there's no marketplace to bring
those items
to to convert them to something else
that's usable
yeah uh we definitely came across that
issue
in doing our research with the china's
new policy that's why
we focused and had that section about
glass because we found that was
one of the more one of the places there
were more
feasible solutions um in a
better market for honestly we found that
you're kind of right that it's a
hard time for plastics right now and did
not find a lot
about um plastic recycling but something
else we did find
was paper recycling and like as
time passes since china's national
sphere policy has been passed
paper recycling facilities are starting
to be built in the u.s
um even in the northeast i think in
pennsylvania
um someone we talked to was telling us
about how that industry
it's taking time to build up the
infrastructure but the infrastructure is
being built up
um particularly for glass and paper
it seems like plastic recycling is
taking a longer
time for the markets to respond to that
and follow it sure and so do you believe
uh
the problem there with the plastic
recycling is that
uh we're still waiting for certain
technologies to emerge
that will handle those kinds of plastics
in a better way than they've been
managed
i think so um and for infrastructure to
shift and build up in the united states
the united states was so dependent
on shipping everything to china it's
taking some time for
those or for the united states to figure
out how to handle that
recyclables on their own okay thank you
so much
that was a very very well done
presentation by the way and my
thanks to all of you who worked on it
all right uh representative bixby
yes thank you for taking my question um
so
uh actually this is this is not my
question but uh
representative kaplan was not able to uh
attend today and he had a
a question a couple of questions um
based on the
written uh present written reports
and one of them has to do with uh waste
to energy
and he noted that there's been some
issues in europe
that um although the
uh the energy conversion technology is
working fairly well uh there is an issue
with um trace pollutants like dioxins
in the exhaust gases that then get into
the environment
and bio accumulate and uh
he was wondering if you had any more
information in terms
of uh ways of dealing with um
with those uh small but
but highly toxic pollutants that might
still be coming out of the exhaust gases
yeah well our project did not entirely
focus on
europe's method methodology i will say
that something that did come up
repeatedly in our conversations with
palm beach county the waste energy
facility over there was that
they implemented an air condensation
process at the end of the whole
incineration
process to just ensure that the steam
that was coming out that has a bunch of
greenhouse gas emissions
was getting um condensated and turned
into water just to reduce the amount of
greenhouse gas emissions that get
emitted into the atmosphere overall
but i don't have a specific uh
way of telling what's going on in europe
okay and uh his other question was
in terms of diversion strategies and he
was wondering
if you had looked at um using specific
ban
specific bands like bands on single-use
plastics
um i don't think we fully got into depth
on fans on single-use plastics it's
something i
came across on a little bit and looking
at
other states policies but not something
we weren't super in-depth into in our
report
thank you and this is this has been a
very both
both groups have done a great job on
your report so
uh very impressed with your work thank
you
all right representative
thank you chair and i just want to say
thank you both for this
really relevant uh presentation uh the
one question i did have quick question
is that you had mentioned that some of
the neighboring states around us are
you know they have ambitious goals to
reduce their waste
and i'm just wondering if those goals
also incorporate the amount of waste
they ship to other states like us
or if they're meeting those goals
without accounting for that
and i don't know if your research
indicated any of that
thank you yeah so from my understanding
from our research it was that
massachusetts in particular they are
trying to
reach a 30 reduction in annual disposal
by 2030 and 90
by 2050 and i understand that this does
include out-of-state ways diverting it
they have banned a bunch of different um
hazardous material and they've also
placed the ban on
food waste ban which i believe is now
getting sent to
new hampshire some of it um and i also
know that with regards to vermont as
well they only have one landfill
and they actually do not take any out of
state ways
and that that might also get diverted to
new hampshire because
there is no surcharge which kelly
probably knows a lot more on
yeah no that's definitely an issue
massachusetts is
cracking down on what and how much can
go into their landfills
um and a lot of this happens through the
private companies
casella works in both massachusetts and
new hampshire and instead of putting the
waste into the
massachusetts landfills is just shipping
it up to their new hampshire landfills
thank you okay and representative
stapleton you have a question
yes uh thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
did i hear you correctly to say that
the waste coming in to new hampshire
from out of state was 49 percent
for in 2018 49 municipal solid waste
came from out of state
thank you follow up mr chair sure go
ahead
um vermont seems to be quite a ways
ahead of us
in controlling the various aspects of uh
waste and recycling how much percent do
you know
of out-of-state waste comes into vermont
and if they've restricted it how did
they do that
they have not restricted it but we
believe it's because there's only one
landfill in vermont
and it is owned by casella and just
because it is such a small state
it's the central landfill for the whole
state they i guess they just decided to
not take any out of state waste which
clearly affects new hampshire because if
it doesn't go there it comes here
thank you yeah and a lot of that is like
decisions being made within private
companies
very good thank you okay any further
questions from the committee
uh yes mr chair i did have one question
go ahead representative murray
uh thank you mr chair and thank you guys
for taking my question i guess to sort
of piggyback
on rep stapleton's question and expand
on that a little bit
did you guys differentiate it all
between public and private landfills
because
i am wondering if some of that
information might affect
what type of waste is taken in certain
places
and what flexibility there is to
regulate some of that
yeah so most of the out-of-state waste
we understand is coming i mean is coming
into the private landfills just because
they have more flexibility of who they
what ways they actually accept
um it's because of the commerce clause
in the constitution itself that the
state really cannot regulate
a whole lot about what their business
endeavors are
however there has been a lot of
community opposition
where these landfills are located just
because it's becoming increasingly clear
that they're
less serving the constituents and more
serving
just their business needs
thank you very much
okay uh looks like we're back for a
second round representative
i'm sorry just a quick follow-on chair
uh casella since casella is in vermont
and they
have vermont doesn't take any
out-of-state waste then how does casella
how does that affect that interstate
compact with regard to them since
they're private companies
we really i i don't think our project
really covered that just because it is
really hard to
find out what is going on in between
their
their own private business and yeah but
from my understanding it probably has to
do with
some agreement that they themselves have
between themselves that they see this
being the most um
like beneficial method for them at least
okay so you're thinking that it's a an
agreement between casella and vermont
uh or more so
casella states can
like flat out say we're not taking any
waste from out of state i believe that
is an issue also with the commerce
clause
okay i'll have to do a little more
research on that i don't know
i'm not fully uh understanding of all
that but uh thank you very
much right uh representative bixby
you have another question um this is uh
actually a follow-up on
uh representative homeless question on
in terms of
so um vermont does have
some restrictions in terms of organic
waste
going into landfills and i think maybe
also construction debris
and with those bands uh created
a disincentive for um
for casella to bring in and bring
waste from out of state into vermont
thank you okay
for other questions for our presenters
today
all right seeing none i want to thank
you all uh
professor shaco uh jeremy emily greedy
kelly randy you all did a wonderful job
this has been
very enlightening and we certainly
appreciate all of the information that
you've passed on to us
and uh look forward to uh
you know future projects perhaps uh
[Music]
teaming up with you guys so if you uh if
you want to do any more uh leg work for
us let us know we'll probably find a few
more things for you to study
most most definitely just let us know
what you've got we'll be glad to
dig into it all right thank you thank
you very much
okay
all right it is 1007. i'm going to take
about five minute recess here and then
we're going to move on
to with the committee discussing um
the retained bills that we have so
we'll be back on in like 10 12.
each
okay
great
[Music]
okay it is 10 12. i'm going to bring the
committee back out of recess
and we'll have a discussion about the
retained bills we have
five retained bills that we have kept in
committee
and we have some time in may
available to us that we could work on
some of these we can't actually accept
anything out of committee until a little
bit later into the fall
but we can do the legwork on any of
these that we choose to now
so i kind of wanted to discuss with the
committee about uh
what our thoughts were going forward and
and kind of share with you
my thoughts and uh representative bixby
and i had a conversation yesterday and
good news is we were on the same page so
uh this should go fairly easy
so uh i'll kind of go through the list
and one by one and i'll share with you
my thoughts and uh representative bixby
and others you're more than welcome to
uh
jump in and fill in uh with your own
thoughts if you'd like
so house bill 366
is the bill right in front of me
yeah that's the animal book sorry thank
you that is a
that bill is one that i sponsored and
i asked the committee to retain it
originally because i knew there was some
more work we wanted to look at
especially in the
criminal justice area of it i have
reached out to
the akc stacey ober and and to uh one of
the other
folks uh eileen landis that gave
testimony
and spoken with them about providing us
with some thoughts and
their recommendations on areas that need
some work in the bill too so
i think that's a bill that we can look
at working on this month
and uh get some of the uh some of that
at least underway even if
we can't get to where the committee
wants to be completely
um so i guess i'll open it up
representative bixby do you have any
further comments you'd like to make on
that
um yeah i think that uh one of the
things that's
convenient about that for start getting
being able to start work on it
immediately is that
there there are no budget impacts so uh
whatever uh whatever
is uncertain in terms of the budget
doesn't really impact how we
go about this one and i think that one
of the
things that we can do is um think about
uh specific people who would be able to
address
some of the uh sticking points that had
been
um that had been raised in the uh
public hearing and uh bring those in
those people in on to help us um as
as witnesses in our work sessions
absolutely agree
my intent is we'll um we'll send this
bill to the
subcommittee for animal protection and
licensure and
and we'll assemble that subcommittee and
allow that to
allow them to take a look at it
any further comments on this from any
other yeah
just just for those people who are um we
haven't done much subcommittee work this
term
so just for those who are new to this
uh when there's a subcommittee the
subcommittee members are the one are
allowed are basically are the ones who
get to weigh in when it's time to vote
on the recommendation
but every member of the full committee
is welcome to come and join
and uh generally the chair of the
subcommittee
is happy to allow those people to
um ask questions and make comments
uh as it goes along
great point and uh i believe i did send
out subcommittee list
assignments to everyone if if i did not
let me know and i will
send them out again the animal
protection and licensure subcommittee
members are follow this it's on a wide
sheet here
it's uh myself representative aaron
representative
dixby representative kennedy
representative davis
representative von plinsky
representative highland
and representative perez those would be
the members of the
animal protection subcommittee
sorry when it turned out it's a little
hard to fall across
okay any further uh thoughts or comments
on uh
on house bill 366.
okay see none will go to house bill 367
which is the uh quarantine bill
that again is a bill that is the
relative to animal health certificates
and quarantine requirements for
animals imported into the state
that again is a bill that i sponsored
i would like to hold that bill right now
i think that there's some other bills
that are
going through process that are relative
to similar areas and i'd
like to let them sort of clear the
pipeline
before we uh commenced any further work
on this bill here
i don't we i don't think there's
anything urgent that needs to be
acted upon right now so
i think it'll be my request of the
committee that we just hold that bill
into the fall and we get an idea of
the landscape of where we are with these
the database and uh the house bill 250
and
house bill 249 we've got several others
that are working in the same area that
i'd like to let them get through any any
thoughts or comments from the rest of
the committee
i agree entirely with that thank you
representative dixie
anyone else
all right see none i think that's the
way we will
proceed okay the next bill is
house bill 438 that's uh relative to the
confidentiality of animal records
databases
this bill as a refresher for the
committee was
sort of dealt with a piece of what the
uh house bill 532 did that
representative bixby sponsored that we
moved forward as a committee and has
now been included into house bill 2.
this uh house bill 438 just went
dealt with one section on
confidentiality and it was our agreement
as a committee that we would
hold on to that bill and sort of keep it
as a placeholder
in the event that there were anything
that we decided
came out of house bill 532 that we
needed to fix later on
i think right now we're uh we've got a
really
good compromise with the senate on
language in what we
have put into uh the budget and they're
currently looking it over again as they
look through the all of hb2 but my
understanding is we're
in a good spot uh being in an agreement
on that language so
it would be my recommendation that we
hold on to this bill of the fall
uh house bill 438 and see if there's any
further work that we need to do in the
animal records database area
any other comments from members of the
committee
well you're all agreeable today this is
pretty easy
okay uh house bill 585
this is allowing the prepayment of dog
licensing fees for the duration of a
rabies vaccination and
reducing fines related there too
actually representative bixby why don't
you speak to this when you and i talked
at length about this yesterday
yeah i i think that um this one the
i think well we decided to retain this
because the bill is written had some
problems
and uh the
but the the idea of potentially making
it possible for people
uh to get a three-year license and
instead of one year a license has some
appeal to it
uh it's figuring out the details of how
that would work
and also making sure that
whatever we do would be
would be workable on the municipal level
so i think we're going to need to get
uh some input input from municipalities
on
whether they would find this useful or
beneficial or
problematic or whether they would like
to
have it as enabling legislation rather
than a mandate
so so those are possibilities um
so i think that uh it we should uh
do some more discussion of it um i don't
see
any reason that we would need to wait
until the fall to start
uh thinking about it
thank you and uh we have we as a
committee received some uh
communication from the bill's sponsor
representative leon that she's very
willing to work with us
as a committee to looking at and address
the
issues and concerns that were raised in
the hearing and any
further ones that we may raise so
it is my feeling i'm in agreement with
representative bixby that this is a bill
that we could start working
on here in may as well and uh
so i i will also assign that to the uh
subcommittee on animal protection and
licensure and we'll have
that bill that they can also take a look
at representative aaron did you have
some thoughts yeah no i just had a quick
question as to
um why was three years chosen
instead of say two years yeah that's a
great question i
i think that'll be a good one to ask
when we get into the subcommittee and
uh yeah i could actually clarify that
um because the uh rabies vaccination is
good for three years
uh uh yeah okay okay thank you
yeah there's again i agree there's
there's some real
the concept has merit there are just
some questions raised and concerns and
uh race and i think we uh
we as the subcommittee and as a
consequently the full committee after
can take a look at that and
see if we can come up with a workable
path forward or at least some further
information
any uh further comments from the
committee members
all right seeing none we'll go on to
house bill 627
which establishes a value-added grant
matching fund for new hampshire
agricultural producers
representative bixby and i talked at
great length about this yesterday
and i think i will actually give the
floor to him again on this bill he has
a lot of background and good working
information on it so go ahead
representative bixby
so um so the this is another bill that
uh where the what happens in the budget
budget
um will probably have an impact on
whether it's feasible
in to what degree it would be feasible
the anything that involves money is
obviously has some complications where
we would find funding for
for this fund is
an open question and having the budget
settled would give us an easier
basis for being able to make those
assessments so i think that we should
hold off until the fall to um
to look at this further i'm thinking it
may actually be
something where we um decide that it
would make more sense to
set up a study committee to look into it
more deeply in terms of
both mechanisms for funding and also the
mechanisms for
figuring out how the granting works and
whether it should be a grant fund or a
loan fund
that sort of thing so um
i think that there are there are also we
had some people who testified in the
public hearing who can
probably give us some good input in
terms of how we might want to further
develop
develop it so i it's got potential but i
don't think we can work on it right now
great thank you representative bixby i
concur i
i think that's uh i think that's a wise
choice for us as a committee to just
hold on to this again a little longer
any other comments from members of the
committee on
house bill 627
all right see none so uh we have two
bills then that we will send to the uh
subcommittee for animal protection and
licensure uh house bill 585 and house
bill 366.
uh we are able to meet on thursdays very
freely because there's no
other committee meetings on thursdays
uh because of the senate hearings so
we don't there's no scheduled hearings
on on bills there's only some
subcommittee hearings
is i guess
is does thursday's work for those
members who will be on that committee is
there a specific
time that or date that works better for
any of you is there any input on that
yeah i think um i'm not sure that uh
there are a couple of members uh who are
not here today possibly because
um it's because of conflict so it might
be
good to send that as an email to the
members of the committee to get a sense
of
um and it might be a matter one thing
that might make a difference is whether
it's in the morning or the afternoon
so i think that might be a better sorted
out by email
we can do that great idea
all right that is all that i had to
discuss i just
wanted to kind of go over those things
as a full committee while we
were here after the presentation and
again
uh i think the students and did a
wonderful job in the information that
they presented and i'm
very thankful that they were able to do
that for us
anything any further information that
anybody in the committee needs would
like to bring up before we
adjourn yeah um i think howard you and i
had talked about
possibly getting uh various people from
unh particularly from colsa
to give give a presentation on how
the work they do would have an impact on
the work we do in our committee
and i was wondering if you'd had any
more
progress in setting up that i haven't
but it is
it is on my list of things to do i need
to uh i need to get on that and see if
we can set up a date to do that because
i think it'd be very beneficial for the
committee to get that input
it's something that for those of you who
are new that we traditionally do
early on but because of the limitations
that we had
with uh the bandwidth on these zoom
licenses i
i didn't choose to take the time early
in the session because the
the time that we had available for it
was needed by other committees with an
awful lot of early bills
so uh we're kind of doing it a little
bit backwards this year
we'll do we did our hearings first and
we'll do our presentations after but
i will uh i will work on getting that
organized and certainly keep you all up
to date
anything else from members of the
committee before we adjourn
all right well then we will uh adjourn
the meeting here at 10 28
and i appreciate all of your time and
we'll be in touch
as we go forward thank you all thank you
chair